(upbeat music)
- What's a four-letter
word for shipbuilding wood?
- Uh, James, are you
sharing your sand toys?
- Do you want a snack?
Here, hold on, have a snack.
- Thank you.
- That's why I'm hungry, it's almost 4:30.
Time for dinner.
- James, you know what, just wait.
Just wait for mommy, I'm
just going to come help you.
You know, I really shouldn't
leave him like this.
- Are you going to
finish this granola bar?
- Einstein, physics, buddy.
You're not going to be able to
climb the slide at that angle.
Has your tutor taught you nothing?
You know what, you need
some more Omega-3s, buddy.
You better come over
here and eat this salmon.
Your brain is starving.
- Hey, check it out.
Oh, hey ladies, how's the Instagrams?
Oh wait, let's do something
for the Snapchat story.
- Oh.
- Oh, it's not recording.
- Who has time for that?
I have to take Einy to ballroom dancing,
and then we have Tae-Kwon-Do.
I have to pick up all of the
shirts for his Mathletes team.
Don't you guys have extracurricular
activities going on?
- Alright, I'm gonna leave.
Bye, Arlo, see you in a few hours.
Mommy's gonna run some errands.
See you guys.
- I'm here! Oh! What?
Hey, you guys are still here?
- Um, wait, where's Sarah?
- (beep) Ugh, that's why my
husband keeps calling me.
Don't go anywhere, guys,
okay, we're going to play.
God, get it together.
That's the second time this week.
Oh, God. (beep)
I don't need that, don't need that.
Come on, (beep), why is running so hard?
I got to work out.
(sign squeaking)
- Come on.